mr gilbert same question to you would
you deploy troops to the southern border
absolutely without a doubt i would
deploy the troops but unfortunately
sheriff lombardo you know we refer to
him among us as sanctuary joe for a
reason department of justice inspector
general's report 2016 at clark county is
one of the worst
sanctuary counties in the nation on may
31st 2016 it was labeled one of ten
jurisdictions that was found in
violation of federal law for not turning
over illegal immigrants to ice
now nevada has the highest illegal
immigrant population per capita in the
nation 223 000 we all know it's much
higher than that that's a direct you
know effect from not enforcing the law
and that took place right here um since
2014 things have just been out of
control with regards to sanctuary city
it's exploded the crime rate by 500
percent so we have to do something if we
don't send you know help down to the
border it's going to continue to affect
us in a negative way we can't sustain it
what's going on here right now so we
absolutely must do something and i would
send our guard down there thank you mr
gilbert um mr lombardo you were invoked
there for a minute uh 30 seconds to
reply is nevada is las vegas a sanctuary
city no sanctuary determination comes
out of the state legislature and our
legislature has not identified
or
labeled any jurisdiction within the
state of nevada's sanctuary
the removal of undocumented felonious
immigrants is done within the local
sheriff's jurisdiction and ability and
within southern nevada i do that on a
regular basis more so than any other
county in the state of nevada and it's
incumbent upon the resources available
via ice and their ability to take those
individuals into custody and remove them
and the 500 percent
that is a fictitious number that mr
gilbert presented thank you